want to know what heating up in theaters  this weekend born in China journeys into  the jungles of China to follow a group  of pandas monkeys and Snow Leopard  [Music]  check out the midge that's not what he  ordered really a meeting between two  gangs turns into a free-for-all  firefight in free fire will anyone  survive we can't all be nice girl oh my  god woman ii can love survive as empires  fall in the period piece the promise  it's just knowing I have to get us out  of here before there's no time left see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]